polite people have it instilled in them
from an early age that they shouldn't
talk too much about themselves a few
comments aside they should to prove
appealing always ask the other about
their lives or stick to impersonal
topics found in newspapers lest they be
accused that heinous charge
self-absorption
but this rule fails to distinguish
between different ways of talking about
oneself there are as well mannered
people sometimes forget better and worse
ways to share details of one's life it's
not the amount that one talks that
should determine the issue only how one
does so there is one particular way of
discussing oneself which however long it
goes on for never fails to win one
friends reassure audiences comfort
couples bring solace to the single and
buy one the good will of enemies the
confession of vulnerability and error to
hear that we have failed that we are sad
that it was our fault that our partners
don't seem to like us much that we are
lonely that we have wished it might all
be over there is scarcely anything nicer
anyone could learn this is often taken
to signal a basic nastiness in human
nature that the truth is more poignant
we're not so much crowing when we hear a
failure as deeply reassured reassure to
know that we aren't humiliatingly alone
with the appalling difficulties of being
alive it's all too easy to suspect that
we've been uniquely cursed in the extent
of our troubles of which we seldom find
evidence in the lives around us the
media offers us unending accounts of the
financial and creative success of others
while our friends and acquaintances
constantly pepper their conversations
with ever so subtle boasts about their
and their children's accomplishments by
an ultimate irony these self-promoters
aren't trying to alienate us they are
laboring under a touching but seriously
misguided impression that we will like
them more for their success they are
applying to social life a model of a
relationship between popularity and
success that in fact only applies in
very selective contexts perhaps when we
seek to please our parents or need the
help of successful people to advance our
careers
but the rest of the time as the Boosters
forget we find success an enormous
problem we put in so much effort to be
perfect but the irony is that its
failure that charms because others so
need to hear external evidence of
problems with which we are all too
lonely how unnormal our sex lives are
how misguided our careers are proving
how unsatisfactory family can be how
worried we are pretty much all the time
revealing any of these wounds might of
course place us in great danger
others could laugh social media could
have a field day that's the point we get
close by revealing things that would in
the wrong hands be capable of inflicting
humiliation on us friendship is the
dividend of gratitude that flows from an
acknowledgment that once offered
something very valuable to someone by
talking not a fancy present but
something even more precious the keys to
one's self esteem and dignity it's
deeply poignant that we should expend so
much effort on trying to look strong
before the world when all the while it's
really only ever the revelation of the
somewhat embarrassing sad melancholy and
anxious bits of us that is what makes us
endearing to others and transform
strangers into friends
we love bringing you these films if you
want to help us to keep bringing you
thoughtful content please consider
supporting us by visiting our shop at
the link on your screen now
you